the associated press is reporting
that dozens of former bush
administration officials george w bush
are leaving the republican party because
they feel it has become the trump cult
at this point in time
uh they are claiming to be dismayed by
the failures of the republican party
including donald trump and his false
claims of election fraud which these
dozens of officials claim is the
catalyst for them
leaving the republican party some
served pretty high up in the bush
administration
they said that they were hopeful that
trump losing would lead party leaders to
immediately move on from donald trump
all unanimously denounced trump's claims
that the election was stolen
of course that didn't happen most
republican officials stuck with trump
and the officials that are now
abandoning the republican party are
saying
they don't even recognize the party that
they once served
as employees of government some have
formally left the republican party
others are moving over to being
independents and they have included
such statements as the republican party
as it
uh as i knew it no longer exists
i'd call it the cult of trump that's
jimmy gurule
who was under secretary of the treasury
for
terrorism and financial intelligence
in the bush administration christopher
purcell
who worked for george w bush said the
number
is growing every day of former bush
administration officials who are leaving
the party or cutting ties with the party
now i have a few thoughts on this first
of all
these are not heroes okay they said
nothing for a long time
if the truth is that they didn't like
how trump was operating
as evidenced by what happened after the
november election
trump operated the exact same way for
the four years leading up to it
trump operated the exact same way before
he even joined
uh the or before he was elected but
after
entering into the republican primary so
you know they said nothing for a long
time
i don't believe these republican
officials would be doing this
if the insurrection had somehow
succeeded if donald trump
after talking about the election having
been stolen
had actually figured out a way to steal
it back which was never going to happen
but if it did
i don't think these republicans would be
saying i'm leaving because it was wrong
for trump to steal the election
they would still have their mouths shut
like they did for the four years that
donald trump has
been president so the headline should be
dozens of bush administration officials
are suddenly desperate to distance
themselves
from the fiasco that their movement has
fueled and pumped up
for decades and this is the most
important thing
when people like you know mitt romney
say something
uh that makes nominal sense and we say
wow there there's a voice of reason
and and whatnot it is true that mitt
romney's
framework is completely different from
that of donald trump
there's no question about it whatsoever
and
many of them may be sincere in their
disdain for what trumpism has turned the
republican party into
but they all played a role in turning
the republican party into that
this goes back to reagan in the 80s
starting with the welfare queen stuff
and appealing to this kind of
anti-intellectualism
that runs rampant on on the republican
side it continued
with newt gingrich uh being speaker of
the house
in the early 1990s i believe i believe
he became speaker in 1994
which was the first midterm election
under bill clinton and republicans
scaling up this sort of cartoonish
um fact-free opposition
to what bill clinton at the time was
offering
and of course it exploded under the
anti-intellectualism of george w
bush and on and on and on so it's fine
for a lot of these people now to try to
save their own skin
by claiming to leave the party they have
every right to do it but
whatever and the the important takeaway
is
not only did they not do this while
trump was president even though the
arguments they made would apply during
the presidency as well
they all gladly worked for
administrations that are responsible
for the conditions that led to a
republican party where trump could win a
primary
trump could never have won a primary on
the democratic side there are
differences between the democratic and
republican parties
there's too many similarities in some
cases but there are important
differences
the reason trump was able to win the
republican primary
relates to george w bush and everybody
who served under him
it relates to george h.w bush
it all relates to newt gingrich and
ronald reagan so yeah okay they're
trying to distance themselves but
uh they they are a big part of why trump
even won the republican primary in 2016.
now
there are also many republicans still
writing off the attempted insurrection
there there are actually some people on
the left as well
writing off the insurrection but many on
the right
still are right-wing terrorism has
escalated to the point
that it almost led to uh elected
officials getting killed
and uh they are now for the most part
with joe biden in office immediately
going back to what about ism
debt and deficit and uh trying to
uh pretend as though the january sixth
insurrection never happened
the the i i hate to even bring this up
but um look up hitler's beer hall push
and why republicans now so quickly
moving past what happened on january 6th
is dangerous
there was this you know laughable failed
coup attempt by hitler
hitler was convicted of high treason
served nine months
and we know what happened later now
i'm not saying trump is hitler all i'm
saying is
it's scary to me how quickly republicans
are willing to move on and pretend it
never happened
and it's scary to me that a lot of
people think this is over
while we have people like marjorie
taylor greene lauren beaubert and others
in congress and most republicans
already pretending that the thing never
went down on january 6 the way it did i
believe that a lot of this has just
begun
i hope i'm wrong i'm worried that i am
right